today we are talking about finding the
right tools
frequently asked questions and editing
in the cloud
i'm priyanka and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news choosing the
right tool for the job
is essential for getting something done
right and cloud technologies are no
different
the right tool depends on highly
individualized criteria
like language support compatibility with
existing tools portability and openness
and cost
while you might not know every product
mapping across providers
you probably have the foundational
knowledge to understand
which product categories are the most
relevant to you
that's why we just published a handy
product map
showcasing similar offerings between
google cloud aws
and azure take a look and find out which
tools work best for you
with all those tools there may be some
technologies you're not familiar with
yet thankfully
our editorial team has put together this
quick 101
guide on some frequently asked questions
and definitions
that can help you get started or brush
up on some concepts
we've just made doc ai generally
available to help you
automate and validate documents to
streamline your document workflows
whether you're sitting on a ton of
unstructured data or looking to reduce
your manual workload
doc ai is the right tool to help what
better way to get started than this
guide and video from developer advocate
anu
to show you how it works cloud shell
editor makes it easy for you to deploy
code to the cloud directly from your web
browser
in this video developer advocate ryan
will show you some of the features of
cloud shell editor
including integrating cloud code
simplifying kubernetes and cloud run
development workflows
check it out and stay tuned for more
videos around how to use it
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud